Now that you've got the files and folder setup that you'll be working with,
how are you going to actually write the CSS to define your framework?
I suggested using a 12 column grid because it's really easy to create all of
the columns that you need, but what else do you think you'll need to define?
Will you need to create a CSS class that includes a row of 100% page width?
A CSS class for a row of one-twelfth of the page width?
Remember, 12 here is coming from the number of columns.
Will we only need to create one column class of one-twelfths of the page width,
to define our columns?
Will we need to create multiple columns of everything between 1 over 12 and
12 over 12 page widths?
That means we'll need to create a column class for 1 over 12 page widths, 1 for
2 over 12 page widths, 1 for 3 over 12 page widths, 1 for
4 over 12 page widths and so on, or, will we only need to create columns of 2
over 12, 3 over 12 and 4 over 12 page widths to create our framework?
Oh and by the way,
the reason I put these dots here is because when you're writing CSS you'll need
to identify that something is a class by putting a dot in front of it.
So it's good to get used to that notation now.
Think about this question, and when you're done check all that apply.